unfortunately this simple life-saving
practice has become part of the
political debate that says this if
you're for Trump you don't wear a mask
um you're against Trump you do
that's why I've suggested that the
president occasionally wear a mask even
though in most cases it's not necessary
for him to do so
senator Lamar Alexander saying the
debate on wearing a mask is turning
political but is it even legal to make
it mandatory twenty-one states and the
District of Columbia now require mass
for people indoors and in public spaces
let's get some insight from former US
attorney Brett Tolman and Brett it's
great to see you again and I see wait we
don't have your excellent Lake City
background but your room looks great as
well um I have I know a lot of people
have been wondering this that we we try
to be respectful we want to do what the
government think says we need to do to
flatten the curve not overwhelm the
hospitals but under what legal authority
is the government allowed to do that to
us
so your state and city governments do
have the ability during emergency
service circumstances to issue rulings
in in essence orders that are temporary
and they are meant to stave off some
existing emergency the problem we really
have here Dana is we're getting
inconsistent messages and inconsistent
treatments across the country and
everybody is noticing it one of the
things that I brought up yesterday with
some friends was just that when you have
a mandatory evacuation in a hurricane
area the government can make you go is a
mask something's a mandatory
mask-wearing mandate something similar
well great analogy and what's gonna be
interesting is they can make that rule
they can issue that order their way to
enforce it is through the use of police
power which the states have and they're
the only ones that can exercise the
police power in that regard so are they
going to do that are we going to start
seeing then arrests now what an
interesting and
and an unbelievable time that that may
be happening right as some of the same
cities are calling and screaming for
defunding of the police indeed and the
other thing is that I think that you see
a lot of these business owners who they
are desperate to get back open this is
their livelihood this is how they serve
their communities and this how they pay
their workers but they don't have any
backup they're the ones having to
enforce the mask-wearing in their stores
because the police don't have time or
resources to be able to go around and do
it for them I'll give you the last word
yeah no that's exactly right and it's
really hard when we see areas that are
different geographically and spacing
seems to be more more you know effective
there as opposed to some of our larger
cities but the thing that really is
difficult as the country watches and
sees the the mortality rate going down
and that the positive tests going up
they're left confused as to whether
we're really in an emergency or is this
more like a regular flu that we deal
with every year yeah all right thank you
so much Brett Tom and good to have you